are men or women the prize
in the room yeah are men or women the
prize
give me give me oh women depressed are
you so women the prize women are
depressed okay wait tell me why because
they're the ones that we're going for
well me personally I'm game for the
woman and I want to go for the women
that I believe is the right woman and
someone who else many people would want
okay go ahead no I made it the prize
um we we run Society we keep Society
going I'm not saying women
of the prize we went on the prize okay
what do you think men or women who's
surprised
[Applause]
let me just
so are men or women the prize in what
sense like in the world or in in the
dating game in The Dating Game
well women okay women are the prize what
do you think nasty 50 50 50. you think
like half women half a man okay fair
enough go ahead men no matter the price
what do you think Auntie
nothing man there's more women anyway so
I can't remember the prices so many of
them running out running out there it's
gonna be men so second question are do
women date up or down
they they up okay up when they can help
you okay do women date up or down uh day
up yeah I answered for me personally up
up okay
they date down they sleep up
yo that's cold
so if women if women date up wouldn't
that make men the prize
that's a good point really
I get the point but I don't I still
don't see men as the prize
why not
so let me get this right you've
acknowledged the point
I understand I understand the point
allow me to finish so you've
acknowledged the point right but you
don't agree can you explain why no I you
asked me who are the prize and relate
question about the on the question
anyway like who's the prize sort of
because then it's like the whole value
thing and all that sort of stuff so
that's why I just said women just to
give an answer that women are the prize
because of
what they bring to a relationship or
whatever it is right I just said it just
whatever but then what was it you said
again that why do women date up I said I
said do women date up or down and so if
majority of the women here said date up
yeah why would and then a man would be
the prize yes but then dating up you're
not dating down so so if they're dating
up then the men are dating down
because oh no but yeah but if women are
dating up
and men are dating down you're saying
yeah women are not the prize that a man
is the price yeah so the men would just
date men because men are the prized why
are men dating down if a man is
surprised when all men just date all
men's
this is
why would men date each other when
they're straight I like this isn't you
just said men of the uh would make men
the price yeah because Ben could date up
but they don't they date down yeah so
then men would be the prize that means
they don't have a choice there's some
women there's some women that would be
up there are some women that would be
down there are women that would be up
like Oprah is up right so then a man has
to be above her to date down to her the
Oprah's not up no I'm just general like
I'm just saying like value money
no no no that's not up though so what's
up then foreign
[Laughter]
a lot of eggs yeah so if she's young and
pretty and works in Tesco yes exactly
yes that means he's dating up yes it
depends on her personality as well okay
Tesco personally she's 20 she's young
she's her body count is zero whatever
then then the man is dating up yeah yeah
do you know her there's some guys that
might want to get her
so she would be considered high in them
so she's high value yeah yeah in the
Dayton Market yeah so then
wait here here's my thing yeah you're
now starting to understand how men think
we we're totally
yeah
so if that is a woman that is high value
yeah and then why would that woman want
to date you wouldn't she want to date
someone high value someone up yeah yeah
right so then
you man who is trying to date up she
doesn't want you crazy
yes yes that's why that's why one in
three men are virgins or haven't had sex
in the past year because nobody wants
them so so you're saying men are dating
down yeah so by dating down you're
saying he's dating someone over 25 30
whose body count is up whose eggs are
cracked and yeah I mean guys look guys
he's dating don't guys will put up with
more than men do so they will put up
with more and date yeah the the guy will
put up with more and date down yeah
because he doesn't have a choice but
he'll still cheat on that woman he still
has a right to not be monogamous sir
because her value is low it depends but
you don't have a choice because no the
high value woman doesn't want you so
you're dating down right but a lot of
high value women die alone because
wait wait wait what are we defining as a
high value sorry I'll explain a lot of
things is
went a lot of eight to ten that are very
pretty dialogue because they can't leave
the streets because they're so used to
the attention like that like what sorry
go ahead then you still use the
attention
um this is like honestly I've just heard
this from guys this is like strictly
this is just the experience that I've
had like talking to guys the last like
two years yeah and they just say a lot
of girls that are like very pretty and
they're given like like that's the most
valuable thing you can be given is
Extreme Beauty like you come out you can
get a modeling contract and girls waste
it and they waste their best years that
doesn't make you high value you're right
you're right sorry sorry technically if
we're gonna go high value woman the man
I misused the term like a high value
woman technically has to be chosen by a
high value man I just meant like like
very attractive women that are like the
most sought after they wouldn't be
you're right I use the rest
yes and I'm saying like a lot of like
the most beautiful women die alone
because they're they're so used to being
like an eight to ten and that's their
whole personality they can't they break
up they've never been bullied like if
you tell a girl she's not special they
freak out which is weird
that would make you low value
if you're if you're beautiful but you
don't have any other qualities you're
still in the streets you're still a
whole you're low value yeah the
equivalent would be a I don't
know a cryptocurrency but well you're
not you're not low value if you're
dating game if you're if you're
beautiful you like oh like someone
that's 300 pounds isn't going to get in
the same like she could have a nobody
count you're gonna get the initial
attention yeah but if you have nothing
else in your home yeah like you hear
your background you've just been ran
through correct correct yourself but
that's that's why I say like girls that
are eight to tens often die alone that's
that's what I was saying because because
they're so used to that attention that
they it's like a drug they can't they
can't they can't so wait wait wait this
is just this is just what I've heard
from men okay so like I'm not sure but
it depends on no but honestly it depends
on your culture your background like
sorry the last if you look at we can go
to like Instagram chicks yeah
the majority of them are single your
Bernice all of them and they may get
gifts they may get dated but are they
kept how many of them do you see that
are kept this is the point that you're
referring to looks only but that's what
that's what we're saying eight to tens
yeah but that's that's low value so wow
no no no so what she's saying is when
you start with looks like we as much as
people want to pretend that you know
this personality stuff matters the
initial attraction is looks yeah so when
you are attractive and you have pretty
privilege yeah you're gonna get
attention so what she's saying is when
you get that sort of attention it's like
a drug you go out and you know that
you're gonna have The Pick of men coming
to attract and move to and talk to you
and sell you drinks exactly right but
you're still not being kept at the end
of the day no one is going to turn that
attraction and those dreams into
marriage in to a ring and they die alone
right I understand that but you could
you could say the same for some men
but
like a dude can be 50 and a girl that's
30 will still find him fine but like
it's not the same vice versa you could
be 50 and a and you're not
attractive as a guy yeah you could be a
guy right most you have all the money in
the world but you just know well mostly
don't turn women on correct most men
have died a lot like I think we're only
40 only only 40 only 40 of men have
reproduced throughout history
so where 80 of women have so the
majority of men do die alone you're
right it's just a new thing for women
because like they they get because they
don't listen to what men want anymore
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible